Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your TLDR.
Android developers, the
Developer Preview of Android N
is now available!
The new release includes
multi-window, direct reply
notifications, and
bundled notifications.
This year we're releasing an
early work-in-progress build,
so you have even more
time to send us feedback.
Check out the post, the
video, and the preview.
Learn exactly what people
expect from a mobile experience
with the new Mobile
Design Hub on
Think with Google-- Designing
for Mobile Micro Moments.
These are intents-driven
moments of decision making
and preference
shaping that occur
throughout the entire
consumer journey.
Jump over to the Hub for more.
Learn how to design your
game for user retention
and more with these tips
from the founder of TapBlaze,
a popular game app company with
over 15 titles and millions
of downloads.
This is the latest post from
the Inside AdMob series,
featuring monetization tips
straight from successful app
developers.
Get insight into how your Google
Cast applications are being
used, and see the impact
of your improvements
by viewing analytics, now
available in the Google Cast
developer console.
Check out the post for
screenshots and more.
Get started building
Slack integrations
on the Google Cloud
platform, with samples
available now on GitHub.
Clone the repository to see
how it works, or fork it
to use as a base for
your own integrations.
And that's it.
A super short TLDR this week.
Don't forget to use the
hashtag #AskDevShow,
and click all the links.
Now get back to work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]